if you're watching this then I'm not
around anymore but don't spiral don't
obsess keep going so how are you a good
day is where I don't go around wanting
to shoot random strangers in the face
and then turn the gun on myself so I'd
leave you a little guides her life
without me you're lovely but you're
absolutely [ __ ] useless
stay active it's not ideal to be a fat
lazy self-pity in London I'm not free go
and if I was you'd be safety tubby
little ginger [ __ ] you know how grumpy
you get when things don't go your awake
you got such a good heart you're born
like it you're just decent this is sandy
that you could enjoy the roses tell us
what humanity's a plague we were
disgusting selfish parasite and the
world would be a better place without us
that the sort of thing you mean no air
Felicia oh Jesus she's dead dad are
English it was you you can't just go
around being rude to people you can then
the dog should be on a lead
oh I'm sorry thank you what he is not a
fat hairy nose he [ __ ] sorry about
that
disgusting if I do and say what the [ __ ]
I want and then when it all gets too
much I can always kill myself it's not a
superpower
that's the worst superhero I've ever
heard of why don't you throw yourself
into your work if that's what the press
people do we're putting out a free local
newspaper that no one cares about that's
not true
[Music]
I've seen lonely people people dying
people in pain I think I've ever met
anyone quite upset something feel front
cover freddie mercury's tooth he's
disgusted by not everyone could get in
the paper and not everyone's finger
Jackie Collins I've you know cheers okay
see you again
you
you